hey guys it is the 7th of July today my
name is jeff mcdonald and you're
watching gamespot news prepare for games
leaking services Breaking and publishers
admitting they've screwed everything up
it's going to be a dramatic day let's
start with games leaking the latest
Witcher 3 DLC was accidentally released
earlier this week but that are pro actor
asking you not to download it the
league's DLC consists of a new outfit
for Siri but said a proactive said we
advise against using it until it
releases officially claiming that the
DLC wasn't ready it might not seem like
enough content to break your game and
it's probably better if you are on the
side of caution but that's entirely up
to you according to SATA project there
are at least three more free add-ons for
The Witcher 3 after this one with any
luck this is all cleared up by the time
we go to air but at the moment the ps4
is yet again dealing with playstation
network issues initially there were
issues being reported with specific
online reliant games but now it appears
that there are bigger problems according
to Sony's official PSN status page
currently affected our Pearson's gaming
and social services PlayStation now and
the PlayStation Store as of 230 p.m. PDT
the ps4 is being affected by all of
these service interruptions and
PlayStation now issues are also
affecting ps3 and other platforms
finally Sega has told Japanese
publication for mitsui that they need to
change up their approach to game
releases and improve their reputation as
translated by siliconera Sega CEO Hajime
satomi I said he strongly believes the
company need to put a greater focus on
quality saying I believe that if we
can't maintain quality it would be
better not to release anything at all he
explored the issues between Sega and its
fans in relation to some of the
company's recent less awesome releases
suggesting that Sega betrayed the trust
of its fans over the last 10 years
satomi explained Sega in the 90s was
known for its brand but after that we've
lost
and we're being left with nothing but
reputation we'd like to win back the
trust and become a brand once again let
me know down in the comments what sega
could do to win you back you can head to
gamespot all we've got stories on the
Xbox ultimate game sale and a destiny
ps4 bundle that is everything I have for
you today as always leave me your
thoughts and feelings in that comment
box and I'll catch you tomorrow